there is no shortage of global crises
these days
between the global pandemic hong kong
israeli-palestinian conflict
the list is long the world relies on the
european union
to offer a united position in defense of
human rights
but lately the eu keeps failing why
it's got a lot to do with one eu member
state in particular
hungary example one last month
israeli-palestinian tensions boiled over
into one of the deadliest episodes of
the conflict
in years the eu wanted to make a
statement
in support of a ceasefire between israel
and the palestinian islamist group hamas
that statement was never made why
hungary
put in a veto
example two mass pro-democracy protests
swept through hong kong in 2019.
after china enacted a new security law
that tightened its control over hong
kong
the european union wanted to make a
statement expressing its concern
over the erosion of human rights that
statement was never made
hungary put in a veto i do think that
that hungary unfortunately betrays the
core democratic values of the european
union
and and there are many obvious cases
where i think none of the democratic
countries
should dare to be to decisions and i
think when it comes to
the issues of hong kong for example it
is clearly
a case like that this is where the
voting process takes place
the council of the european union in
brussels
depending on the issue decisions are
made by a simple majority
qualified majority or by unanimous vote
by
all 27 eu member states
eu foreign policy decisions require
unanimity to pass
but if eu members cannot even agree on a
statement to defend human rights
what does it signal to the rest of the
world hungary
rejects the eu's criticism of its recent
veto
saying quote according to treaties of
the union
full agreement is needed on important
issues such as
foreign policy hungary therefore acted
in accordance
with the basic treaty when it vetoed to
accuse hungary of being
non-european because it exercised its
right
set forth in the treaty is in fact
deeply
non-european of course hungary has the
right to v2
but the problem is twofold first of all
hungary
usually vetoes decisions that aim to
express
the value commitment of the european
union especially when it comes to
foreign policy systemically vetoing such
decisions
uh is undermining uh the values of the
european union and undermining the
already pretty weak
uh foreign policy leverage of the
european union so this is one
problem the other problem is is
that hungary has gradually become
the most pro-russian and most
pro-chinese
member state within the european union
hungary has been defying consensus and
using its veto card in the eu
partly because it wants to increase its
economic ties
with china and to do that it needs to
align itself politically
with china hungary is both an eu
and nato member but since orban took
office in 2010
he's been openly pursuing an eastern
opening strategy in the hopes of
attracting chinese investment
the coronavirus pandemic has moved this
strategy forward
at the beginning of the pandemic prime
minister viktor orban himself
inspected tons of supplies that had
arrived at the budapest airport from
china
ventilators protective gear and more
in the latest move toward china
hungary's foreign minister announced the
country would begin to produce china's
sino-farm
in 2022. hungary is also the only
country in the eu
to inoculate its citizens with the
chinese kovid 19 vaccine
not to mention the diplomatic ties the
welcome ceremonies for the chinese
premier league young in hungary
and various visits by orban with
president xi jinping
in china the implications of hungary
turning to china
are concerning for the eu especially for
nato security
a detailed report by hungarian
investigative outlet direct 36
documented how the country's eastern
opening policy
creates a friendly environment for
chinese intelligence
in short making budapest a spy hub
there's an increasing number of chinese
students flowing in
to the country and china is known for
using
its citizens forcing them to feed
information
to chinese intelligence and of course
china is mostly not interested
in what's happening in hungary they are
not interested in hungarian high tech
because
there's there are none one of the most
controversial chinese projects in
hungary
is yet to be built by 2024 shanghai's
fudan university wants to open its very
first european
campus in budapest at this site hungary
plans to finance the mega project
reportedly through a 1.5 billion euro
loan
from a chinese bank construction will be
carried out
using chinese materials and labor so
who benefits hungary i think
has vetoed the the most
in favor of china so china is the number
one beneficiary of hungary's disruptive
power inside the eu
but we don't actually see chinese
foreign direct investment
flowing and pouring in to the country
some say that in order to to gain the
trust of the chinese
you have to develop a relationship
on the long run so it means that you
need to put a lot of effort and years
and years
to convince them that you're a trusted
partner
not all hungarians are happy with the
government's close
ties with china and they are taking
action a couple thousand protesters
gathered at budapest kosciutzka recently
to stop the planned construction of food
and university
and to demand affordable housing for
hungarian students
instead at the planned construction site
of the campus
budapest liberal mayor korachon has put
up new street signs
he is a key critic of orban the science
now read free hong kong road
or dalai lama road an attempt to
underline
that possible political and economy gain
should never outweigh speaking up
against human rights violations
so what is the purpose of the vetoes
exercised by orban's government
that hungary only vetoes the decisions
that they feel
that are rather symbolic therefore
do not they do not really block anything
but at the same time
this way he can send gestures towards
beijing
towards moscow and towards other
illiberal and authoritarian states that
you have an ally within the european
union
hungary obviously serves as an outlier
and wants to be an outlier
and i think it clearly undermines the
image of the european union
the the leverage of the european union
and also the the european union's role
as a kind of democratic model for the eu
to live
up to its credentials as a defender of
human rights
it needs to find a way to bring hungary
back
into the fold
you